vous vous êtes déjà regardé dans un
miroir de très très près là je vous
promets que vous pouvez vous faire peur
vous allez voir qu'il se passe de drôles
de choses sur notre peau il y a même des
monstres à huit pattes qui se
[Musique]
promènent vous avez déjà entendu parler
des acariens ces toute petite bêt ce
sont des animaux microscopique enfin des
monstres plutôt vous imaginez s'il
faisait notre taille et bien certains
vivent sur notre peau on les trouve
principalement ici près du nez ou au
niveau des cils et des sourcils là ils
sont installés à la base du poil dans ce
que l'on appelle le follicule pileux on
estime qu'il peut y en avoir plusieurs
millions sur le visage tenez en ce
moment ça grouille sur le mien et sur le
votre aussi quoi mais c'est dégoûtant
j'ai pas ça moi ces organismes
appartiennent à la classe des arachnides
ce sont donc des cousins des araignéers
et des Scorpions mais impossible de les
voir à l'œil nu ces petites bêtes ne
mesurent qu'entre 01 et 0,6 mm pour les
observer on a donc pas le choix il faut
un microscope celui-ci grossit les
objets jusqu'à 600 fois alors ça peut
paraître énorme mais il en existe de
beaucoup plus puissant les microscopes
électroniques eux peuvent grossir plus
de 10000 fois le plus puissant du monde
s'appelle Titan Crios il se trouve à
l'Institut Pasteur à Paris il fait 4 m
de hauteur et permet une vision à
l'échelle atomique le mien est beaucoup
plus modeste c'est un modèle tout à fait
courant tout à fait abordable puisque
neuf il coûte entre 100 et 200 € mais
d'occasion celui-ci n'a coûté que 50 €.
mais revenons à nos acariens pour les
observer et il faut d'abord les prélever
et pour cela je vous conseille
d'utiliser du ruban adhésif j'en détache
un petit morceau et je vais le coller à
l'extrémité du sourcil là où les poils
sont le moins résistant ça fera moins
mal au moment où je décollerai ensuite
il faut être patient compte une bonne
demi-heure le mieux d'ailleurs c'est de
chasser l'acarien la nuit il préfère
sortir dans l'obscurité vous collez le
ruban adhésif en début de nuit et vous
le retirez au petit matin
voilà je pense que c'est bon je retire
le ruban adnésif délicatement je dépose
le scotch sur une lame je glisse la lame
sous la lentille pour observer ce qu'il
y a sur la lame il faut une source de
lumière en général les microscopes en
sont équipés ou alors il possède un
petit miroir qui va permettre de capter
la lumière extérieure ou bien celle
d'une lampe moi j'en ai rajouté pour y
voir encore plus clair j'ai réussi à en
piéger un oh là là et en plus il bouge
vous avez vu ces petites pattes alors il
existe de nombreuses espèces d'acarien
celui-ci est un demodex folliculorum
vous savez je vous ai dit qu'ils étaient
installés dans les follicules pileux
alors d'où viennent-ils et bien ils nous
sont transmis par notre mère juste après
la naissance on y
retourne on voit bien les quatre paires
de pâtes qui caractérisent les
arachnides et puis à l'extrémité des
pâes des petites griffes elles leur
permettent de s'agriper aux follicules
pileux justement en revanche à cette
échelle on peut malheureusement pas voir
que le corps est couvert d'écailles
elles leur permettent un meilleur
ancrage dans nos follicules ou dans les
ports de notre peau on voit bien la tête
hein et au bout de la tête c'est la
bouche ils s'en servent pour manger les
cellules mortes de la peau qui
s'accumulent dans les follicules ainsi
que le sébum vous savez le liquide
huileux qui est produit par nos glandes
sébassé voyez les acariens ne sont pas
très beaux mais ils nous sont très
utiles et contrairement à certaines
croyances leur présence sur notre peau
n'a rien à voir avec l'hygiène ne
cherchez surtout pas à vous frotter
frénétiquement le visage pour les faire
partir vous n'y arriverez pas les
zariens font partie de ce que l'on
appelle notre microbiote cutané et là
depuis des millions d'années et
croyez-moi ils sont bien accrochés ils
ne présentent pas non plus de danger
pour la santé toutefois les
scientifiques pense que un surnombre de
démodex peut provoquer des démangeaisons
ou des rougeurs ah j'allais oublier
quand les zariens sortent la nuit c'est
pour manger mais aussi pour se
reproduire sous nos
yeux ça se fait
pas ça y est je le vois vous savez ce
que et entre mes doigts un cheveux et
c'est pas bien gros un cheveux entre 012
et
0,07 mm alors au toucher il a l'air
parfaitement lisse mais grâce au
microscope vous allez voir que c'est une
parfaite illusion pour mieux observer il
en faut
[Musique]
plusieurs ben non il en a
plus
aïe 1 2 3 j'espère que ça va suffire
ensuite vous connaissez la mécanique on
dépose les cheveux sur la lame et
ensuite on retient son souffle un cheveu
ça ne pèse qu'un mg il suffit d'un
souffle pour qu'il s'envle alors pour
qu'il reste bien en place et bien on les
recouvre avec une petite
lamelle on est passé un cheveu de la
catastrophe et ensuite on vient placer
la lame sous le microscope pas de geste
brusque
lumière et c'est parti et quand on y
regarde de plus près et bien on voit que
mon cheveux ressemble un peu à un Tron
d'arbre ou plutôt à une tige de palmier
on voit des sortes d'écailles en réalité
ce ne sont pas des écailles mais des
cellules qui se superposent comme les
tuiles que l'on trouve sur le toit de
nos maisons elle forme la couche la plus
externe du cheveux ce qu'on appelle la
cuticule qui recouvre d'autres couches
en fait les couches sont disposées de
manière concentrique la cuticule
recouvre une première couche de cellule
le cortex qui recouvre à son tour une
autre couche nommée La médula c'est le
cortex qui est responsable de la couleur
des cheveux grâce à la présence plus ou
moins grande d'un pigment qu'on appelle
la
mélamine alors un cheveux sain comme le
mien c'est vraiment du solide à diamètre
égal il a une résistance comparable à
celle de certains métaux tenez lorsqu'on
tire sur un cheveux et bien il peut
supporter un poids d'environ 100 g et
maintenant je vais vous montrer à quoi
ressemble un cheveux abîmé mon coiffeur
m'en a gentiment donné un un cheveux
blanc détérioré par le temps
contrairement à mon cheveux qui est sain
celui-ci est éventré on peut voir
nettement aussi que des morceaux se
décollent et puis son cortex et sa
médula se retrouvent à l'air libre c'est
un peu comme si on avait coupé le Tron
d'un arbre en deux alors malheureusement
pour le propriétaire de ce cheveux les
écailles ne se remettront jamais
complètement en place il faut les couper
et les laisser
repousser ça devrait
suffire je vais vous montrer ce qu'il se
passe à la surface de la peau quand on
transpire et cette fois je ne vais pas
utiliser le microscope mais cet
instrument c'est un endoscope une petite
caméra placée au bout d'une tige on
l'utilise en principe en médecine pour
voir l'intérieur du corps mais là on va
diriger la caméra vers la surface de ma
peau à un endroit précis l'une des
parties du corps ou avec la paume et le
front on transpire le plus le bout des
doigts et ce que je vais vous montrer
est incroyable vous voyez le bout de mes
doigts apparemment ils sont parfaitement
secs et pourtant la peau y est couverte
de soueur ça ne se voit pas à l'œil nu
ça ne se sent même pas au toucher et
pourtant je suis bien en train de
transpirer regardez on voit de petites
perles d'eau qui sortent c'est dingue et
si vous faites bien attention on peut
même deviner les Pors de ma peau ce sont
ces petits points on dirait même des
petits cratères en moyenne un humain
sécrète 1 L de suur par jour quand il ne
fait pas d'effort mais lorsqu'on fait du
sport la corde à saué par exemple ou en
période de chaleur et bien on peut
perdre beaucoup plus jusqu'à 8 L d'eau
dans une journée la transpiration est un
mécanisme naturel qui permet de réguler
la température corporelle en la
maintenant à 37° elle permet d'évacuer
la chaleur et de faire baisser la
température de l'organisme c'est ce
qu'on appelle la
thermorégulation le phénomène est
intéressant j'en ai parlé plusieurs fois
dans les vidéos ce n'est pas de l'eau
chaude qu'on évacue pour se refroidir
non la chaleur est évacuée quand la
sueur s'évapore pour passer de l'état
liquide à l'état gazux les petites
gouttes de sueur que l'on a vu pompent
de l'énergie dans la peau de l'énergie
sous forme de chaleur et c'est de cette
manière que nous régulons notre
température corporelle voilà j'espère
que vous n'avez pas eu trop de suur
froide que ce voyage dans l'infiniment
petit vous a plu surtout n'hésitez pas à
liker et à nous dire ce que vous en avez
pensé je vous dis à dimanche prochain
chers épicurieuses et épicurieux et
d'ici là portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
bien